good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy
Wednesday it is hump day don't forget to
hump someone you love speaking of
girlies that I love hey Jax wow what are
you doing here
speaking of turdies that I love I am
here to do a job Claudia a j-o-b
litterdia it's like the darkness in rice
lituria it's like it's
oh my God welcome back everyone happy
Wednesday best day of the week except
for you know Thursday Friday Saturday
and Sunday yep
um yeah hope everyone's having a great
day thus far I'm having a great day
because I'm sitting down with my girl
we've got much to discuss some of it is
much too good for children it's so true
well I'm surprised you uttered that line
given the story from your upcoming
comedy special yeah though if you're in
the know you're in the no and if you're
not you'll have to tune into my comedy
special coming out soon when when
such a good question I don't know cool
cool cool so long process you know
editing artwork you've just been in the
editing Bay like constantly if you don't
understand me and these editors like
we're in this editing room together it's
we call it the Cutting Room
um it's just been it's an exhaustive
process girl I know
um I've been doing a bit of editing
myself and so I know what it's like to
have to edit I know you do it's
it's kind of like
it's kind of like cathartic almost you
know yeah while also extremely stressful
well it's going to produce wonderful
fruit for you turdy when we get to see
your special thank you I'm excited for
everyone to see it but I'm more excited
for today's episode we've got a lot to
discuss it's Wednesday which obviously
means to your toasters and we have some
some ones we have one that revolves
around reading yay oh my God I'm wearing
the perfect sweatshirt the redheads so
that's something we need to discuss okay
we also have just like good stories you
know Kelsea ballerini's big interview we
got to talk about a check-in I both
watched it that's the big one we just
got like a good show you know and that's
always good it is always good you know
what else was a good show our episode of
freaking Fred last night Claudia and I
did our live show on patreon so how it
works is it's live like in the good old
days you know we do YouTube live people
are popping off in the comments we're
talking about pop culture just cracking
jokes and it was hysterical you can
watch it and listen to it on patreon.com
toast you can get the replay
um but it was a moment in time you know
it was a moment of time it was chaos
because when we first went live I forgot
to set it like as a private link just
for our patreon members so if you
subscribe to us on YouTube one of our
114 000 subscribers uh you got a
notification like oh my girl these are
live and then I had to end it like a few
minutes later so I'm sorry if that was a
tease um that was just that was my
mistake it was completely where was it
like promotional because then all these
people tuned in they're like what are we
watching and then you cut them off you
cut off their supply and then maybe they
have to go to patreon so there were like
Whispers you know the rumor mill people
saying I did it on purpose like for
click bait promotional purposes and I
wish I was that smart I think it's more
believable that I'm that careless
instead of that smart so I mean I'll
take the accolades yes marketing Queen
but it really was it was a genuine
mistake I don't know we're known for our
click bait these days turdy we are we
talked about that on the patreon we we
spoke about a lot of the patreon I feel
like it's really never been a a better
time to join the patreon so much content
there you get access to our backlog of
like a couple hundred episodes Vlogs
podcasts sisters guests Jacks Claude
it's really I don't really I feel like I
would be an insulting to your
intelligence to sit here and explain to
you why you should join the patreon like
you you're smart enough to know it's
just like a natural extension of the
show and so often like we tell a story
on patreon or like have a thought and
then we don't say it again on the
Regular Show so if you just want to have
the full 360 of Jackson turd patreon.com
the toast full 360. for the 360
experience 360 degrees
full circle
that is true
it is a fact
that it is
[Laughter]
um so yeah we've got a great show but
before we dive in Jax like tell me
what's going on with you you know who
has Jax Jax is good thank you for asking
so since freaking Fred last night
I wouldn't say I have anything to report
to the group
um
I washed my hair
I went to sleep that's big I woke up I
did my hair
you know that's kind of that's kind of
just like this circle of life as a woman
I honestly find like the hamster wheel
of hair maintenance to be frankly
exhausting yeah and today was the day I
had to do hair from scratch so hard so
so that was that day
and I think the day where you have to do
hair from scratch is kind of like the
worst hair day like day two is the best
but you have Nails in your hair
electrocuted pieces yeah sticking up you
have your not like you don't have those
natural oils to Tamp them down uh and
usually my day of first hair is Monday
thank you I switched things up because
oh because it was we had Monday off so I
was like I don't need to wash my hair
what is your usual hair washing schedule
such a great question wow you asked for
the best questions I'm kind of like the
interviewer of my generation usually
it's Sunday night me too and Thursday or
Friday night if I can make it oh wow I'm
a Sunday Wednesday Friday oh wow yeah
actually
that's a lie I only not like I wash my
hair twice a week but it's only because
I don't really get oily hair unless I'm
using a lot of product which eventually
I do towards the end of my cycle because
I like to put it up but it's my hair
hurts
I need the in-shower scalp massage
that's why it happened so so glad you
brought that up what is that my hair my
hair hurts like at the root especially
like the back of my neck kind of like
the base of my skull what the [__] is
that and the only way to get rid of it
not a massage not anything is you just
have to wet it like you have to wash
your hair shampoo conditioner and brush
it not even the shampoo conditioner I
just I need to get it wet like I need
the follicles to like reset or something
yeah it's like kind of like turning your
cable box on and off like what the [__]
is that I don't know but that's what
gets me down every time by the way same
so if I can make it to Friday I do that
way I wash my hair Friday night I if I
don't have plans over the weekend I
don't do my hair at all and then I get
my hair gets two days off and then
Sunday night we do it again for the week
my hair washing schedule is definitely
based on my social events calendar of
that week so it's hard to say like which
days exactly like you know this week is
kind of crazy because tonight I have an
event you know
um so what I would usually wash my hair
but I'm not what event could you tell us
or um yeah it's just like a birthday
gathering I want to give a major shout
out to you know someone who's special
here to the toast fills in for us both a
lot friend of the toast happy birthday
Taylor strecker it's her 40th birthday
and we love you girly and thanks for
being a friend of the toast and a friend
a friend to all a friend to all she's
she's a good girl that Taylor tracker
yeah wow happy birthday Taylor strecker
that's your reminder if you're listening
to the show and like you know Taylor
send her a text you too you know oh my
God totally is it today yeah I'm gonna
do it right now you know thank God I
spoke to her yesterday and like I knew
it was her birthday but like I I'm so
bad we gotta bring back Facebook I know
people I've actually asked like how is
everyone remembering people's birthdays
since Facebook has kind of fallen off
and everyone's like you know when you
text someone happy birthday your phone
will ask if you want to like add it to
your calendar so that in the next year
and the year after that it'll give you
like a notification like it saves it's
not the same no and you know I think
it's best if like
we get to a point where we only know the
essentials birthdays you know so true
it was meant to be so true I wasn't
meant to know every birthday of every
person I've ever met no and then it kind
of added this like layer of like
pressure toxicity like well how many
people wrote on your wall for your
birthday oh she got 100 I got 150. you
know it was like it was toxic yeah so I
think this is better it should be like
word of mouth I sent my text feeling
good yeah good I'm glad I reminded you
so why didn't you go to Carrie Underwood
last night
that's such a good question I had plans
to go to Carrie Underwood
um and I just have like a really busy
week and I was either gonna go to Carrie
Underwood or see my friends from high
school who I haven't seen in so long and
like I chose Carrie Underwood and then I
was like you know what
I'm choosing me
are you not Carrie
I'm not I'm not and um I looked up the
set list and like I have a really like
Niche taste in Carrie Underwood music
like not before he cheats and Jesus Take
the Wheel you know like yeah I like like
other [__] and her tour is very much
like a greatest hits because especially
in New York it's not like a really
Country Market so the the setlist like
wasn't like making my labias flutter you
know so I decided to I decided not to go
okay
um I'm sure you don't regret your choice
though snitches stories really looked
pretty amazing it did look amazing but I
didn't feel like fomo especially I
didn't even say this but if you listen
to patreon and you have a 360 degree
view of Jackson Claude you already know
claude's plans for this weekend are
quite sickening and I do find them very
sickening even though my reaction last
night was giving nothing
um was it yeah because I had a thought
going on in my house I checked my phone
for the first time and I just got
distracted it's totally fine um yeah so
I decided very last minute to hop on a
plane this weekend go to Vegas for 24
hours to see Adele because if I have to
see one more sickening Tick Tock about
this emotional show and not experience
it like what am I doing this is my year
I'm saying yes to life so I'm like you
know what I don't need to see two
concerts in one week that's like kind of
a lot it's excessive so I decided to
lean in with Adele even though by the
way like I don't know what's going on in
Vegas this weekend but um
I cannot get a flight I have my hotel
booked at my flight home book I cannot
get a flight out United or Delta there's
something always going on in Vegas some
trade show best yeah that's right is it
you know the EDC or whatever I don't
know I just kind of want to put it out
in The Ether because it sounds like a
lot of people are going from like New
York to Vegas like if is anyone firing
up their jet give me a ride you know I'm
great in flight entertainment I'll sing
I'll dance I'll be quiet whatever you
want you know yeah yeah I'll sit on the
toilet I can't I don't know what I'm
gonna do it I gotta get to Vegas like
the only there's like one 7 30 flight
with a middle seat all the way in the
back I'm not flying out at 7 30 a.m
especially because Vegas I'll get there
at 7 30 a.m yeah and I ain't sitting in
a middle seat I ain't sitting in a
middle seat not for Adele
no no who would you sit in the middle
seat for Taylor
honestly no like I'm I I can't like it's
almost like when you don't do something
for so long you like I've been sat in a
middle seat I can't tell you because I
won't like I'll take a more inconvenient
flight I'll take a a more expensive
light like I will do anything not to sit
in the middle seat especially since I
started traveling with Brian I have all
these like travel hacks like I have
really figured out a way I can't tell
you the last time I sat in the middle
seat now to the point where I haven't
done it in so long I can't even imagine
it yeah to sit in a middle seat as a
Solo Traveler
you gotta really want to get there
yeah and I do and like I will I'll
figure it out I'm like I have all these
seat alerts I'm like I'm just waiting
for one [__] seat maybe like a
[__] aisle to open up the people that
you're going with have tickets yet well
you know Brian is uh right here he's
going to Denver first he has to work so
I'm like you know what maybe I'll just
[__] go to Denver because I can't get
my ass pretty you can't do that I know
I'm thinking I'm like I'll take a
One-Stop flight I think I would prefer
to take a One-Stop flight than sit in
the middle seat they're just it's just
so unreliable too I know you know you
have to pray that your one flight gets
there let alone two no it's so true and
then double the dark economics these
dark Economic Times yeah it's you never
know it's crazy
I've been blaming these dark Economic
Times like for everything I'm always
saying that I'm like oh my God like the
train is late Stark economic time no
like the trains are not okay
no everything is like especially like
the transportation sector is not okay my
heat in the um in my studio yesterday
was freezing my nose was running the
entire show because the heat was out
um and it's because of these dark
Economic Times I mean it costs a lot to
run your energy now 100
economic time 100 percent
um so I feel like I've been so consumed
by this Kelsey ballerini interview like
I watched last night this morning I read
so much I'm ready to talk about it okay
cool I watched half of it this morning
um I got a lot of the gist and then also
you'll share with me any uh interesting
factoids that I missed okay yeah how
much did you watch I watched the full
thing I got I think I'm up to the all
the talk about the couch
oh you still have a ways to go hold on
where am I
well not a Waze it was only 45 minutes
but yeah I am at oh 22 minutes left no
left I have 22 minutes oh okay listen
for a second to see what she's talking
about
to get everything checked to see if I
could freeze my ass oh about having kids
yeah okay so let's dive in no uh yeah
without further uh do to do about our
hair washing schedule and concert plans
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know
yes you wench you you wench
when she's such a term of endearment now
like it's like I want to call someone a
wench in a negative way but it's like oh
do I love this person no by the way okay
I'm so glad you brought that up because
that's how I feel about [__] I'm like
hey [__] and
I have like found myself in situations
where it's like she called me a [__] no
I didn't [__] like it's really to me
it's not a negative word I'm taking my
power back I I don't like it it cuts
because you're a wench that's fine when
she's a softer term
but like when Maya called Lindsay a
[__] and then she's like did you just
call me a [__] she's like I meant it
friendly I'm like no you didn't no by
the way that's exactly what I was
referencing I don't think that Maya
meant it like [__] I just think when
you're having an argument with someone
and you call them a [__] like it's
probably unfriendly because you're not
calling someone a [__] if you're like
hey if you're like come on [__] like
you know you know what word I use in
place of that where it's like actually
really condescending but it's a totally
fine word it's actually the opposite I
say it in a condescending way no but
it's a word that is totally fine girly
girl like girl oh
girl some people saying about a man and
like that's even meaner that's that's
mean yeah for sure no that's like I'll
be talking about a man who's like not
doing something right I'm like girl
I just want to say like justice for the
word [__]
uh I don't feel
the same but I will not stand in your
way
no I'm just saying like the experience
you have with wench is the experience I
have with [__] you can understand the
experience
the [__] is a swear word
swear word you are literally turning to
a teacher like with every day that
passes by on the show which is a cuss
word turdy cuss word put it put a
quarter in the cuts jar and when she's
just an underrated term I mean I agree
but I think back in the day someone
would have considered wench a cuss word
oh
they considered everything a cuss word
100 percent
at least we'll always have one you know
until you can get clearance for saying
[__] just don't have one just don't
call me a [__] please okay
sure [__]
when you look at bags of dog food you'll
see pictures of bright carrots and juicy
steaks but when you open the bag all you
get are stale smelly pellets dog food
needs some fresh thinking only the best
for Bryson streis it's real food at the
farmer's dog if you're feeding your dog
the farmer's dog it's real fresh healthy
food with whole meat and veggies it's
gently cooked in human grade kitchens to
preserve their nutritional value how it
works is you'll tell the farmer's dog
all about your little stress bro and
they'll deliver personalized vet
developed recipes for as little as three
dollars a day the meals are
pre-portioned they come in ready to
serve packs and because they're
delivered on your schedule you'll never
run out and more importantly you'll
never leave the house
it's convenient and fresh dog people all
around the country have ordered millions
of meals from the farmer's dog it's
never been easier to invest in your
dog's health with fresh food because
who's worth it more than a stressed
brother
get 50 off your first box of fresh
healthy food at the farmersdog.com toast
plus you'll get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50 off
that's the farmersdog.com toast because
Brethren all around this great nation
deserve fresh healthy food today Thea
will be having turkey from the farmer's
dog for breakfast because it's delicious
and good for him enjoy
first story Morgan Evans Kelsey
ballerini the drama so in chronological
order a few days ago was announced
Kelsey ballerini was going on call her
daddy yesterday or the day before like a
teaser inner a teaser for the interview
dropped with like little bits of
information and then last night before
the interview dropped Morgan Evans
Kelsey's ex-husband posted a statement
on his Instagram so this is in response
to probably the interview and the EP
that goes in on the details of their
marriage she said this quote it's really
sad for me to see this person who I
spent so much of my life with and loved
with all my heart saying things that
aren't reality and that leave out what
really happened she knows I'm not the
type of guy to speak on those things
publicly if this is what she needs to
heal I hope it helps and all I ask is
that if you're on my pages please don't
be mean don't be mean to Kelsey don't be
mean to each other Life's too short
I know that this statement had like a
bunch of words written out but to me it
just said victim victim victim please
don't be mean like okay first of all
lest we not forget it is so important to
remember
you started this morning You released a
song first and that was like kind of my
biggest frustration but to call her
daddy interview was like I really wish
she had asked Kelsey like about her
decision to kind of lay it all out there
did it have a lot to do with his song
would she have done it
anything yeah which have said anything
there were so many holes in the
interview but like that one for me was
the most frustrating because that's like
what I'm so curious about especially
given the fact that now we have the
statement yes and so I read a quote from
um the interview a part that I didn't
get to yet where she talks about how she
was angry about him releasing the song
she said I was so angry so angry I had a
pretty good grasp on my grieving Journey
until that song came out and I was livid
I think that maybe there's a world where
he was blindsided I did not Blindside
him two things can be true I felt really
upset in that moment I felt really used
in that moment his healing journey is
his healing journey I respect that but
publicly exploiting that feels a little
nasty to me before it's final so is it
like it was nasty so she got nasty or
was it only nasty because their divorce
wasn't final
I think um that pull quote is a little
out of context misleading because what
she was saying was like to do it so
quick after we decided to get divorced
like it was all about the timing I don't
think she was really that angry that he
released a song but it's like we haven't
even finished this yet like we're still
going through this really nasty process
and like how can you have processed your
feelings enough for a song when like
it's not even over yeah it had a lot to
do with the timing okay according to
Kelsey okay so to me his statement I
feel like he's saying three things one
um it's not true what Kelsey is saying
is not the truth it's likely as we say
her truth he has his truth and there's
the truth but I feel like anybody who's
watching the interview could
realize that like she's talking about
her experience no and I think anyone
who's like rational or anyone who has
like experienced divorce like knows that
two people can both be speaking and be
contradicting one another but can both
be telling the truth right but it's like
you know what do Morgan's friends think
there was wrong in their relationship
like they not everyone sees it the same
way and that's of course just normal
um yeah but I just thought this like you
have a lot of gall too
to like kind of Shame someone for doing
something publicly but like you you open
the door
yeah so Kelsey is free right now because
you started it yeah
I don't know I feel like there's a
difference between like putting your
feelings into a song like a vague you
know Song and all he was really saying
is I would have you know crossed the
world over for you which we know from
Kelsey's interview like he would have
didn't yeah he would have but he did it
by the way I would have used the word
subtle for his song like it was actually
really
um like clear and direct
yeah it didn't need to be like you know
extrapolated and pulled apart it wasn't
like Poetic in the sense where it was
like analogies it was actually like very
clearly directed towards of course but
it wasn't saying it didn't take anything
bad about like her character or anything
just that like he loves her and he would
have done anything for her like the
thing is that's nice I actually I
actually do think it was like it
mischaracterized her because and that's
what she was so upset about the song
really made it seem like she's like
known forever that she was just like
playing a part she knew that it wasn't
gonna work and just like couldn't could
not wait to get out of there fast enough
yeah
no and when she says like no we were
separated we were fighting we barely
started on the couch like we were in
counseling like this is not a surprise
like you would like yeah she says in the
robin like are you just blind
right right
um
so like Morgan's giving victim mentality
which is like annoying
um but let's talk about the interview
okay because I really felt like
we got a lot out of it I mean we got a
lot out of the EP so I don't feel like
there was like that much that we got
from the interview that wasn't set in
the EP although I do think the biggest
bombshell was that they actually did
have a prenup
um which I'm glad Alex asked that
question because like how could you not
when you're in that industry and I feel
like you have so many people around you
who are just like making money off of
you and are always going to be concerned
about your money
um
that are obviously going to be pushing
you in that direction so I was like
relieved to hear that but Kelsey just
basically was like like but I had to
give him half the house and Alex was
like you didn't have a prenup she's like
no I did but we had like messy language
in the prenup about alimony so I was
given a choice I either give him half
the house like we sell it and split the
profits even though we didn't put equal
money down like I put way more money
down he contributed and we should have
split the profits based on the
percentage of money that we contributed
but I could have either given 50 50 of
their house or had to pay him alimony
until the end of time no until he gets
until he gets married again but nobody
you want to be done with this person
like they don't have kids together they
never need to speak again why should she
be sending him payments every month like
no I I yeah and so she just gave him
half the house and so I think she made
the right choice that's what she meant
in her album when she said you got half
yeah there was a lot of stuff in the
interview
um it seemed like money was like a big
thing yes in the relationship yes uh
like she had a lot and he did not yeah
and she could do a lot and he didn't do
some of the things not that maybe he
couldn't or just that he wouldn't
um it was kind of reminding me a little
bit of that patreon episode that we did
where it's like the women have to do
everything for the husbands like because
she was saying how like if she didn't do
stuff like they wouldn't do anything
they wouldn't take a trip the house
wouldn't Gap the cleaners come like all
this stuff right it's like that's just
sometimes that's just like men but like
when it comes then on top of also being
a breadwinner oh yeah but also
the fact that like most marriages like
you're with the person 24 7 like you
guys are connecting all the time but if
she's having to like beg him to come and
see her to book a flight to literally
send him a car and make sure he gets on
the plane till they come and see his
wife like that's not a marriage no and
there's more to a successful like
partnership than money so people
contribute to a marriage and a life in a
family in ways that are Financial but
then also in ways that are different
like building a home and making time for
one another so I don't think she was
necessarily mad about her having to pay
for anything if she had felt like there
were you know equal efforts being put
into all the other stuff yes and I think
like traditionally the historically like
men have paid for stuff and women have
done everything else and now she's in a
role where she's doing everything else
and paying for herself and paying for
stuff and that's right and that's it's
[__] it's unbalanced yeah so I
actually like totally understood her
frustrations that because I saw some
feedback being like why is she so
obsessed with money and it's like it's
not really about that it's like money is
a way of contributing to a marriage and
there are other ways to to contribute to
it too that are just as valuable as
money but if you're not doing any of
them then yeah I'm gonna grow resentful
of the money I'm contributing and the
planning and the cleaners and the trips
and the anniversaries and everything
yeah
so I felt like we got a lot from the
interview mostly because Kelsey was so
willing and like eager to get this off
of her chest like it's obviously
something that's been plaguing her for
almost a year now
um but I found myself getting so
frustrated during the interview like
Kelsey would just give these like really
kind of beautiful and like honest
answers filled with delicious follow-up
questions
yeah oh my God I was like screaming I
was just like wait no ask she was like
we just had two totally different ideas
of what marriage was yeah okay so what
was your idea and what was his yeah she
also said in the beginning like
um
what I thought I needed in a
relationship versus what I actually wind
up needing in a relationship like oh
what did you think it was at 22 and what
do you need now at 29 like yeah so like
if you if you listen to the whole EP
which I have many times I feel like I
didn't learn that much that I didn't
already know but I think this was a
really good moment for Kelsey to like
obviously promote the EP and also have
people get to know her because she came
off really well because you know you
want to just [__] annihilate this
person because you're you [__] hate
them and I feel like she really did her
best to like to handle the whole thing
with like Grace and composure because
anytime she like went to say something
like kind of sharp she was like when
Alex was asking her like do you feel bad
about like putting stuff out there about
you moving on knowing that like there's
this person who loved you who could see
it she was like no like it's not my
responsibility to care anymore and I
think she like almost felt bad she was
like but I hope he has people around him
who can like protect him from seeing
stuff that might hurt him I feel like
she really went out of her way to like
say her piece but also still be kind yes
that was what I liked most about the
interview because I think a lot of it
was the same as like what we were
getting from the EP but like I've never
heard Kelsey speak for that long she's a
really yeah thoughtful smart caring
person and yes you could tell like she's
a people please turn that she's never
gonna just be like well [__] you all but
she's really like coming into herself
she's very confident but those things
take time and like she's grown up in
front of us all these years and I just
liked listening to what she had to say
she's a very calming voice and I felt
like even when she would like tell her
side she always left room for like
but I wasn't perfect either you know I
never got on a plane I'm only buying
tickets and I could see that being his
criticism like you thought yeah paying
for everything meant you didn't have to
show up in Amsterdam for me yeah no
you're 100 right like she she made a
point many times to say like I also was
the problem too like I'm just speaking
to my experience and you're right she
was so thoughtful and so mature yeah and
it's clear she's like some someone who's
like she has like a lot of trauma when
it comes to relationships I guess her
parents went through like a really
really messy divorce but not me getting
choked up and she was like I grew up an
only child like all I wanted was sisters
yeah sure getting choked up oh my God
yeah like I was so like moved because
she was like honestly one of the
greatest blessings from this experience
which is just also a really mature and
like positive way of looking at
something like this is like I have such
amazing female friendships because my
friends showed up for me in this like
major way and she told this really cute
story about her friend showing up for
her in LA and like what it meant to her
um and I was like getting emo because
like you know these are things just as a
person with sisters like you take for
granted yeah I liked when she said even
though it was sad she said La makes me
sad because by the way so relatable that
should be a song dog
100 well that's literally John Mayer I
don't think I want to go to La anymore
it's so relatable like I actually
um like I knew what she meant yeah and I
think also as like a a country artist
countries I constantly like it's in its
own world and it's very like not really
acknowledged by like mainstream pop so I
think even more when she goes for work
she feels even more a little bit like an
outsider yeah and she's like trying to
break through and she's doing it on her
own and she's probably just like the
country girl yeah always like the token
country girl yeah so I actually feel
like this interview was probably really
good for her like to be opened up to a
new audience although I do wish
she had been she'd been talking to
someone who had like a like a deeper
knowledge of country and like the
landscape like who who is Morgan Evans
to Kelsey ballerini if you've never
heard of either of these people you
don't know that like she's really this
queen of country music and she is like a
very very long career ahead of her like
very Carrie Underwood Vibes and he was
like pretty popular in New Zealand
um came to the states started fresh had
this album and then like once he got
married like kind of like went nowhere
um I I wish there there had been more of
uh for people who don't know and for
because I want everyone to know Kelsey
and I want this to be like I'm a huge
fan I want this to be like as good as
possible for her I wish it was just more
uh context as to like what the landscape
is and what the dynamic was yes and
because it wasn't just like Rich versus
poor no and also I wish that there was
more context in terms of like the
trajectory of her career and the
trajectory of their marriage and like
when your first album came out and like
the reception towards that like how did
that affect your marriage because we say
this all the time like was her success
in any way like threatening towards him
but also it's not like she had overnight
success she's been working really hard
and they've been working really hard so
like at what point
did she really like blow up and and what
happened to him because the fact that
they met they were both hosting the CMT
Awards like shows that they started in
the same place similar levels yes so if
they had stayed at similar levels like
would things have been better like if he
had had as much success as her
yeah you know I feel like we've kind of
speculated for so long that her taking
off had to have contributed to some sort
of like jealousy or insecurity but she
really didn't bring that up I feel like
it actually wasn't a factor
or at least one not a big enough one
that she spoke about it yeah
I agree except like just like the money
that comes along with it but I feel like
he must make like he's relatively
successful he's not Kelsey ballerini but
he's not like
a nobody
I don't know how we make money like does
he write other songs like you know I
don't know right that's true that's true
that's true
I don't know but all I know is like I'm
I'm I'm invested in country and like I'm
never hearing about him ever
yeah although I will say probably one of
my favorite songs of the last 10 years
is by him yeah no he's a really great
artist he's he's not not talented yeah
we dream two Wings we dreamed into Lego
and they actually had a song together on
his debut album that was so beautiful
sweet and then um so I hadn't gotten
here yet but she talks about her not
being ready to have children and I think
that became like a big Catalyst in them
splitting up because yeah you know time
had run out he didn't want to be an old
dad and she wasn't ready to have kids
she wanted to freeze her I said 30 she's
29 now he didn't take that well I did
not realize he was nine years older than
her me neither plus knowing he was so
traditional makes sense that he would be
like eager to have kids and
and heard a career taking off her being
nine years younger it makes sense that
she's not ready for kids
um but what she had said was like
it was a question of like do I want to
have kids yet do I want to have kids
with this person yeah and the
conversation about kids was like a real
accelerator for her to like bring up the
word divorce yeah because that's when
you should all get off the pot yeah
exactly so that makes sense then why
they got divorced when they did and if
he wants to be a dad soon then then
hopefully he could find someone who who
knows that that's what they want right
now
right it's just when you marry someone
at 22 like you know as a 29 year old
like you know that they don't know
themselves fully yet yeah that's the
thing and that's I feel like why people
are always like cautious and like
warning young people against getting
married soon I feel like that's what I'm
always saying because I got married so
young it's like you really do grow up
into a different person and you could
grow up into a person that your partner
hates yeah and I really feel like that's
what happened like he liked the kind of
impressionable young
um go with the flow people pleaser girl
and then the older she got she came into
her own she started having success she
became an adult and he did not like that
version of her but that's who she grew
into yeah
it's not gonna work
so it
it was it's just a really interesting
thing and I'm finding it so interesting
how many people are like getting
invested when they don't know him and
you know and they're maybe not even like
country people yeah
like I feel like if you're not country
like you've probably heard of Kelsey
because she goes to like a lot of events
and she's oh again like always she's the
country spokesperson she's the face of
country music for women especially
um but you definitely don't know him
yeah well maybe now you will and what do
you think do you think he'll put out
more music next like
she's done like okay he put out his one
song that was like it's pathetic
um now she put out a whole album she's
gonna go on SNL and perform these songs
she went on call her daddy like she said
everything that she needed to say like
do you think he will do anything else
she did say like she wanted to release
the CP do one interview and then never
talk it about it again so this is all
we're getting I believe oh I mean it's a
lot there's nothing to say yeah there's
nothing more to say I don't know I feel
like if if he is you know opportunistic
which she did allude to towards the end
especially
um when it came to like taking the house
from her she was like that was something
I never saw and like a lot of my friends
had said you know he has a lot more to
gain from this marriage and you do like
it's you know he could be being
opportunistic
um if he is that person then yes if he
actually wants to close the chapter and
like not be tied to this and like just
do more things on his own then no
we'll see we'll see but also it's like
you're an artist and you talk about your
feelings and like this is what you're
feeling yeah that's what it's maybe not
opportunistic it's like cathartic the
same way it was cathartic for her to
write her EP and do her I know some
video and and put that out there yeah
so
we'll see but what's interesting is we
never get interviews like this about a
divorce because people usually have kids
and they would never never philander
like the father or the mother of their
children in that way so it's really like
interesting to know all the details of
someone's marriage now no the questions
were like so detailed and like I just
almost like invasive like sleeping on
the couch what was going through your
mind it's like oh my God like it was it
was so deep yeah which we never get
because most people like I can't think
of one divorce where someone sat down
like less than a year later and
literally went through every single
fight they had and and since the
beginning since the beginning it's the
beginning
yeah no it's so true it felt foreign and
anytime someone does do an interview
they say you know well they're like you
know the father making sure someone said
and it gets like a little bit and we I
said from there you know it reminds me
of like Chris and Cavallari Jay Cutler
yeah Kim you know you don't say anything
about Kanye
um
so it's just interesting to get like but
no when you're not you're not ever going
to be tied to this person ever again
like [__] that yeah no I know love that
yeah no but we it just we never get that
I'm really happy for Kelsey I feel like
she's really being seen as like an
artist and a songwriter and a singer and
like people out of the country genre
because album's like not that country
it's kind of like alternative almost
leave me again is like country but it's
not like a twangy like you know no no
um yeah so I think it's like really good
for like her career and I'm so glad
because I feel like we've been like
preaching about Kelsey ballerini forever
and I just think this will be so good
for like SNL is so big and I'm just
you're right it's giving like Olivia
Rodrigo it really is it's really
reminding me of that what do you think
she'll perform on SNL
I'm glad you asked blindsided for sure
really yeah I feel like that's the song
at least on Tick Tock like that's like
what everyone's oh I only know it from
like what I'm enjoying I feel like it
should be mountain with a view and seven
a.m and I'm on a mountain with you and
leave me again
yeah actually do you not think she'll
perform anything from her album that
she's still promoting I know by the way
like I just need everyone to know like
just because there's this EP like do not
move on from subject to change like it's
so it is so [__] good I feel like
she'll do one in one
I know I don't know I think she's going
to lean into this Olivia Rodrigo moment
I don't know I think she'll do like the
the radio pop what is it uh her first
little things uh she did a tick tock
with one of her songs what song was it
your secrets by the Dozen oh that wasn't
nowhere my skeletons sleep
hypothetically if you ever kill your
husband hand on the babble I'd be lying
through my teeth uh dirt on you I think
it's called okay I think she'll do one
like radio song from subject to change
subject to change and leave me again
I saw this video on YouTube of a CMT
music video where she likes to get some
stuff and then she sing her song she's
saying leave me again and she sounded
unreal and if she did that on SNL she'll
have fans for life yeah she did a cm2
storytellers which I've been like seeing
clips for and I cannot find the full
[__] episode CMT like Channel being
this like obscure Channel where like
sometimes you get it and sometimes you
don't like it's where's the channel yeah
do you know what I mean
CMT Crossroads I know they picked up
Nashville like where does the CMT
Channel Live question mark it's like
around if you have cable it's like in
the 200s with like mtv2
okay I'm never going up there I don't
even have those channels but I for me I
have the random channels on YouTube TV I
might have CMT
for me the highest I go is 52 HGTV if
anything's happening above 52 like I
don't know 52
um
I think we do get CMT on YouTube TV
because I think also DCC making the team
is on CMT
yes it definitely is did you love that
premium channel you know they are always
putting Clips on social on Tick Tock of
um like crazy [__] that gets said like
out of pocket [__] it's like girls
getting yelled at for like having one
tooth that's like a little more yellow
than the other one like really detailed
like being overweight yeah of course you
gain three pounds you're fired yeah like
it's it's kind of this like [__]
crazy show it is but like let them be
like that's what no like that's that's
what it is to be DCC okay so there's one
place and if you don't like it like
literally go anywhere else that's that's
like the franchise they built yeah it's
so Southern it's so Cutthroat it's
[__] it's wild yeah no they're not
changing for anyone no
um so stream Kelsey ballerini is subject
to change while you're at it it's so
good yeah I'm still on what rolling up
the welcome mat
um I am too but like
but like don't sleep on subjects no I'm
I'm sleeping like I'll let you know
because I was sleeping on it before
um wake up like we could do something
about it just yeah it didn't
um
I don't know it didn't pull me like yeah
not every like I don't know maybe if I
listened again maybe you're wrong I
think when I first put it on it was like
more upbeat and I was looking for
something more somber or vice versa I
forget
um no she also released the album like
around a time when there was a lot of
good albums coming out it's like it was
just overwhelming I think it took me
like two weeks to finally settle down
and start listening to it okay I'll give
it what I did right now I'm listening to
Pink's album
oh my God I was listening this morning
really good so far agreed that PR thing
she did with Kelly Clarkson where they
sat down and sang a bunch of songs like
that was the best promo for her new
music because I was like damn wait I
actually haven't checked it on pink for
sure I just want to say I loved it like
loved it I don't want to complain
because we don't ever get things that
are so amazing but it really felt like
they were singing like parallel to each
other and not together
I feel like Kelly was like connecting
with pink and pink was like just
connecting with the camera and pink was
connecting with her music and I feel
like Kelly was like wait let me just
like oh and yeah it won't feel bad
actually it wasn't like a Harmony it was
just like two people singing in
different rooms put together no I was
giving split screen for sure
but I loved it no because uh I like it
and if you want to know what that's from
it's from kind of our viral Tick Tock
sound oh yeah somebody like posted a
clip like just a funny toes moment and
people were using the audio I think it
has like 2 000 uses wait let's do it
let's do it do you feel like you want to
talk less [__]
um no
because
I like it and also Michelle and Rachel
from The Bachelorette did it or Gabby
I have no idea you didn't see the video
of the two batches no I know Michelle
okay anyone who came after Michelle in
the franchise it was Gabby or Rachel
they did a video I think Clayton's
walking in the background like it kind
of I'm gonna say it's Rachel and it kind
of like was a big deal in The Bachelor
World using our audio yeah no like
influencers speaking of a big deal in
The Bachelor world you are on a podcast
today yes yesterday my episode with my
twin Victoria Fuller
um which was like so fun because it
really just came through I didn't know
her I followed her on Instagram I think
she maybe followed me
um
we spoke about her on the toast about
how like we were Twins and she like
reached out and we started dming it was
like so organic you know and then she
came to New York because she was
launching a podcast she was like banking
a couple interviews she was like would
you come I was like yeah I mean it's so
much fun and the interview came out last
night it's called uncensored Saints
that's her new podcast with Victoria
Fuller
check it out I saw some clips it looked
really funny we were being hysterical me
and Tori she's funny
she's funny and she's like gorgeous yeah
like
let's be nice yeah literally must be
nice oh my god
um very cool also I'm on good guys this
week were you like literally have
today's Wednesday and we have one two
three four five podcast episodes that
were on that you could listen to
yeah Jackie's on Good Guys people are
kind of hailing it six because we did an
episode Monday on patreon
people are hailing it it's like the good
guys like best guest yet are they they
are I haven't really like dove into what
the people are saying cracking up but I
saw Ben posted a real that was really
funny I was really funny
so funny you are
me me no I'm shy no it was funny
you are they were loving it yeah no it
was a really great episode we talked
about like a lot of fun stuff they're
always talking about food those two oh
my God oh my God tell me like the whole
conversation on what everyone like
orders from a Chinese food restaurant
honestly I have like a toxic
relationship with food without telling
me like they're always talking about
food I was feeling inspired by Josh's
order I'm not gonna lie what did he get
oh my God everything but he was making
it sound like so mouth-watering and I
was just like do you guys just talk
about food for an hour yeah pretty much
by the way I try I tune in like most of
the time whenever I can
um but when I was on tour like it was
when we had long car rides like it was
what I would listen to exclusively
they're so funny they're kind of like
the male toast like they're so like out
of pocket and really like have a niche
and if their Niche is talking about food
yeah and like weird cultural like weird
social interactions yeah it's one of my
favorite podcasts it's so good it's so
good so if you want to be introduced to
it in a way that feels you know natural
and familiar earlier your girl Jackie O
is on it and Claudia did an episode a
few weeks ago so I did check it out
check it out that one we didn't talk so
much about food we talked so much about
like being famous because like Josh
actually is you know right right and I
had like so many questions
must be nice
yeah must be nice
okay ready for our Second Story I know
by the way we are moving so
[__] we are but we already have
45 minutes oh my God the rest of these
stories are we're gonna cruise through
because they're all like small stories
not how many of your toaster they're not
like think pieces you know right right
like the Kelsey is a think piece agreed
the next story is brought to you by Lumi
do you want to smell better naked let's
face it our underarms are not the only
place we have odor I mean that is so
true that's why we're excited to tell
you about Lumi whole body deodorant for
pits for privates and Beyond Lumi was
created by an OB GYN who discovered
improved in clinical testing that the
vagina is not to blame for day-to-day
odor below the belt so she developed
Lumi a uniquely formulated ph balanced
deodorant it's aluminum free skin safe
and clinically proven to control odor
for up to 72 hours we also have a
special offer because our new customers
are going to get five dollars off the
Lumi starter pack with code toast when
you go to lumide.com that's
l-u-m-eodorant.com I love Luby I feel
like ever since I've been saying yes to
life like I have full days and full
nights sometimes you just don't have
time or like let's be real the energy to
take a full ass shower in the middle so
Lumi is just like a great way to refresh
I like that they target all different
parts of the body not just the armpits
because I feel like historically that's
what we've done
um it smells great it's I feel like it's
really a brand you could trust developed
by OB GYN it's a whole body deodorant
it's aluminum free it's baking soda free
it's powerbin free it's pH balance for
safe and use below the belt so Lumi
starter pack is perfect for new
customers it comes with a solid Stick
deodorant cream tube deodorant and two
free products of your choice like a mini
body wash and a deodorant wipe and it
has free shipping so it's a special
offer for our listeners new customers
are going to get five dollars off a Lumi
starter pack with code toast at
lumide.com that equates to over 40 off
your starter pack when you visit l u m e
deodorant.com and use code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
Perfect bar if you're looking for a
protein bar that actually tastes good
look no further than perfect bar with
their lineup of fresh from the fridge
protein bars perfect bars exactly what
you've been looking for no chalky
artificial aftertaste here they're made
with freshly ground ingredients like
ground nut butter organic honey 20
organic superfoods perfect bar has a
variety of products like protein bars
little snack size bars that are also
good and good for you you'll be sure to
find something you love no matter what
your taste is personally the dark
chocolate chip peanut butter with like
little sea salt flakes on top is so good
I love that you keep it in the fridge
because when the ingredients are so
fresh but also like something about cold
chocolate is it's pretty fire if I may
um perfect bars saved our ass on
staycation I don't know is anyone else
want to ever go on vacation like we're
always hungry like you eat your meal but
you don't have like snacks in your room
100 Zach had packed a few of the perfect
bar snack size bars and they literally
got us through to the morning because
like we didn't have to eat that much we
were truly full and satiated and then we
could carry on with staycation and their
non-GMO project verified gluten-free soy
free kosher and low GI thank you perfect
bar for seeing our community perfect bar
knows that it'll be Love At First Bite
so for a limited time they're offering
you a chance to try their refrigerated
protein bars for free here's how it
works sign up for email or text and
upload a picture of your receipt from
your local grocery store they'll
reimburse you for the cost of one bar
directly into your venmo or PayPal
account all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
free perfect bar today that's perfect to
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking enjoy this is
just Ariana Dubose poking fun at the
memes of her viral bafta's performance
I'm so glad oh page six Shady Ariana
Dubose finally found her sense of humor
after going viral for her disastrous
2023 bafta Awards performance you're
[__] brutal oh my God that was the
nastiest sentence
her sense of humor it's a little extreme
after going viral for her disaster I
wouldn't say it was disastrous no people
are now hailing it as Camp yeah so bad
that it's good yeah the West Side Story
star who has become a meme following her
name dropping rap signed off on a round
off of memes and tweets making fun of
her viral video obviously someone stole
her phone on her PR team and just got to
work so good
um someone posted a tweet that said when
Angela Bassett wins the Oscar she must
start her speech by saying and in the
words of Ariana Dubose I did the thing
Angela did the thing Ariana Dubose
commented honestly I love this
sure I'm so glad I'm so glad I know it's
probably not real I know she's probably
like still reeling probably feeling
embarrassed maybe someone had to do this
for her or force her to comment this but
you know what from a forward-facing
perspective it's good because she
shouldn't have deleted her Twitter
deactivated her Twitter it makes you
look like you can't you know poke fun at
yourself and you're taking this so
seriously so this it's the Lea Michelle
method you've got to get in on the fun
in order for like things to kind of
simmer down yeah and so don't take
anything so seriously and like make the
most of this moment do a viral Tick Tock
like get some followers yeah you're so
right Angela Bassett did the thing
because it's harmless it's not like real
controversy it's harmless which is why
it's so fun yeah get involved get
involved just loosen
you know joking your panties in a wad
just loosen up yeah even if she like
can't actually it doesn't actually feel
that way like someone on your team like
steal the phone make some funny stuff
agreed so that's some exciting news uh
that was exciting exciting mindless news
I just want to tell you again how like
you made us get a box of tissues in the
studio and how I'm not really I know
I've said this before I'm not a tissue
girl like I'll use a paper towel I'll
use my sleeve I'll use the toilet paper
but just having a box of tissues and
like first of all the texture of a
tissue is really incomparable to even it
was designed for your nose like I find
myself if I go back and watch episodes
from like even this week like I'm con I
have a tissue in my head at all times
there's nothing even coming out of my
nose but I'm always just like you know
that's funny I play with my bobby pins
the whole time I just like tap them
together I wonder I pay no one's ever
said anything but like that would bother
me to watch I play with the core I'm
constantly but our chords on the YouTube
like come together so it also if we both
put our hand put your hand on the edge I
know it looks like we're holding him it
looks like we're holding hands
speaking of love
Devin Booker has unfollowed Kendall
Jenner fans blame the rumored Bad Bunny
romance okay there's a lot going on here
this one goes out to Amy Devin Booker
has stopped following his ex Kendall
Jenner on Instagram and fans speculate
that the model's rumored romance with
Bad Bunny is to blame
so
a few nights ago Kendall was spotted on
like a group hang date with Bad Bunny
leading people to speculate that they
might be a new item Kendall Jenner and
Bad Bunny that [__] Booker Kendall's ex
has now unfollowered her making people
think that like maybe she really isn't a
new romance because I didn't when I
first saw the pictures I I just thought
like they were you know they have mutual
friends they're both famous like they
had they needed a meal and they went to
dinner
um but now I'm really starting to think
about what this could mean and I think
it would mean amazing things yeah
um I also think like maybe we don't need
a reason why Devin Booker unfollowed her
like you're not seeing someone anymore
like why do you have to follow them like
yeah exes are are out of your life for a
reason also she's been posting like
really sexy stuff on Instagram fire
flames that's Sunset Beach dress with
the sleeves connected that was a moment
oh no of course but she's always like a
fashion gorgeous girl no she's been
posting like naked pics
get a girl which is like not Ken the
Kendall we know like all the other girls
do that except kind of Chloe
um yeah and it was kind of shocking
she's in the mirror like holding her
breasts yeah being sexy
oh wait maybe she was trying to catch
the attention of one Latin Pop Star and
it worked yeah but I also could imagine
why Devin had to unfollow her like
seeing his naked Gia xgf on Instagram
like that hurts yeah I just don't know
that we need like a full-fledged FBI
investigation as to why Devin Booker
unfollowed Kendall like they're not
together anymore yeah but I do hope it
has to do with the fact that she's moved
on yeah I I really ship her in bed bunny
I mean talk about two people who are so
equally matched in terms of looks I mean
I honestly don't know Who's hotter yeah
and as we said on freaking Fred last
night if you want all of our thoughts on
us processing this information for Amy
um check out our episode of freaking
Fred but yeah this is what the
Kardashians need like we said they need
a high profile relationship you know the
next Kim and Kanye they're in a funk
like they are in this like like funk I
feel like no one's talking about them
everything like nothing they're doing on
social media is giving I don't even
think they're trying but like you know
Kim made this Tick Tock with North and
one of her friends it turns out her
friend is Mariah Carey's daughter and
then and then Kim and Mariah Carey got
in The Tick Tock like fake singing it
did nothing for me like I didn't feel
any of my loins you know do anything
I totally agree I'm really not into the
tick tocks
oh I think they're like harmless and fun
they're like they're hard I don't think
they're harmful but I'm not into them
like they never do anything for me I
Kylie's do she does them so sporadically
they're So Glamorous I'm sorry I meant
that Kim in North account but Kylie does
so many things for me you know Kim and
North are like posting a lot which is
just never good you always want to like
leave the people wanting more like I get
it it's just like North's thing and
Northway experience but like can't North
have a private account she needs one
yeah so she could do her thing like we
don't need to see all of it like Express
Yourself
right there yeah over there no like it's
just
it's not she's like a little girl like
just the whole world doesn't need to see
her tick tocks I agree I think that's
what Kanye was trying to say yeah in a
moronic way but I didn't think he said
she should go on private
yeah no he didn't want her there at all
yeah
are you ready for our next story some
romance rumors
oh God what now you sent this to me
what Lucas Gage and Chris Appleton start
dating rumors with vacation pics yes by
the way I I have a lot of thoughts on
this okay Lucas Gage and Chris Appleton
spark dating rumors after the two shared
photos on vacation together at the Saint
Regis Punta Mita Resort in Mexico on
Monday so the White Lotus star Lucas
Gage captioned his picture the best at
Chris Appleton
one antagon Saint Regis and hashtagging
them so maybe they had a free trip in
his Carousel of picks Lucas and Chris
pose for a picture while sitting on top
of an ATV the duo also took a selfie
with helmets and bandanas over their
faces while inside the vehicle
you know this is so interesting to me
because you know
Chris Appleton is very much like a
behind the scenes he's not a celebrity
himself even though in a weird way just
because he's so good looking and he has
such high profile clients and he's so
talented like his JLo looks and his Kim
looks like he's really become like a
star even though he's a behind the
scenes guy he's a world-renowned hair
stylist so I like love this
um I think people are always like shook
to find out like that's what he looks
like because he's never really in front
of the camera yeah he's a handsome man
he's gorgeous and I'm obsessed like I
love this moment like yes Chris Appleton
like be a star no and like they even
though they're both Hollywood guys like
they come from different parts of
Hollywood like Lucas is an actor Chris
is like a hair stylist but I think
they're equally matched I think they're
yeah like equally successful and and
hyped over and I think this is really
cute you know people like thirst
over Chris Appleton so for him to
actually like be giving us something in
terms of a relationship like in a
private life I'm obsessed yeah and I
feel like Chris Appleton has like a
really high bar I could just see him
being like
no you're ugly oh add this to my list of
regrets oh can you get your phone out
Claudia I know everywhere
as well
when we actually had Chris Appleton on
the show many moons ago I was headed to
the airport right after we recorded So I
said was that like a slob so was that
okay we were going to the CMA Awards in
Nashville we were doing Red Carpet the
next night so we got spray tents the
night before so we had fresh spray tan
so we were orange clowns and you don't
wear a lot of makeup when you have a
fresh spray tan because then you have to
like wipe it all off so we like were
just like ugly wearing airport outfits
looking orange like Oompa Loompas and I
had airport hair like I was literally
just like in a dirty bun and Chris
Appleton came on the show and was
talking all about hair and like the more
we were talking to him the more we
realized like how legendary he was and
the uglier we felt and I'm sure he never
wants to come back because we were two
[__] slobs but if he ever came back
just know like I would whip out my fine
I would wear my prom dress yeah but he
would think that wasn't cool either like
that's what I'm saying about Chris
Appleton like he's so Discerning you
know like you need to be wearing like
I don't know like a full saline look I
know I was I'm like really disappointed
in us for how we handled that you know
what I actually eventually like watched
some of it back I don't know why maybe
it came up on a clip on Tick Tock and I
look so much better than I thought that
I did okay maybe it's worse in our minds
yeah cause I'm tan I'm skinny like
what's bad
such a good one like my hair was in a
low bun and he moved it into a medium
bun it was like a fun experience no okay
he's not coming back but at least he
told us about that color wow shellac
that changed my [__] lives hello I
have it right here I use mine this
morning I know he's like a spokesperson
for Colorado so he gets like paid but
like I trust him and with this [__]
shellac [__] oh my God in case anyone's
people are always asking Color Wow pop
and lock high gloss finish shellac it's
the best [__] that's what we used to put
on the top of our hair to smooth
everything down if I'm doing an updo I
use it
um and it also gives her hair nice shine
people always say we have shiny hair we
do have like naturally shiny hair but
that also helps yeah thanks Chris yeah
so I think we need to change the
narrative yeah we should watch the
interview I'm sure we were like so
effervescent our usual selves
I don't I have so much pain like I have
Claudia I can't even listen to my like I
can't I can't listen to an episode
that's for more than a month ago I agree
it's just I have pain sometimes I can't
listen to the episode from that day
uh
I usually can like like if sometimes
I'll see a real from the day and I'm
like I can't watch this again skip yeah
like I'm talking it's taking too long to
land the plane for sure but then we like
go so quick and I'm like slow down woman
this podcast could be as long as you
want it to be
so true not today not today not today
not today not today wait I have a
thought just hear me out
what if we did deer toasters tomorrow so
we don't have to continue rushing like
we're already at an hour tomorrow's
Thursday like I kind of a slow day
usually like today we just had like big
caller daddy stuff I agree why don't we
wait for a slow day yeah and I had I
have I have really good submissions and
I want to be able to like you know give
them slow down I totally agree that's
that's what I mean okay um I hate when
we have like one episode that's an hour
20 and then the next one's like 50 40
minutes yeah yeah not 40.
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story I am good because I think this is
a thought piece oh okay here we go
Chief's fans are sickened by boozy Super
Bowl Parade have you seen this I did I
saw some backlash I didn't read much so
you need to give me the details okay
some Chiefs fans don't agree with how
the team celebrated it's Super Bowl 2023
title the Kansas City Star published a
series of letters to the editor Sunday
so the local paper that criticized
Chiefs players for drinking and for
drinking excessively during their parade
and for using the arrowhead chop a
submission from Janet who lives in
Liberty Missouri for using the what the
arrowhead chop it's their um signature
uh gesture and I think it's uh deemed
offensive
cool a submission from Janet who lives
in Liberty Missouri wrote that the
team's ownership and head coach Andy
Reid should have prohibited alcohol
during the parade which had which Janet
said looked like a college fraternity
beer bust Janet said quote if the Chiefs
cannot go a few hours without alcohol
the organization has a problem I for one
was sickened to see this for the second
time some Chiefs even bragged through
social media about how the drunk they
were afterward I am ashamed that players
I cheered for could barely walk after
they got off the bus no doubt the
spectacle made the news in other cities
no Janet only you are making it make
only you I just want to say that sounds
like an over dramatization but I kind of
have like a hot take
I feel like we're about to like Freaky
Friday our takes on this I know because
you're like mocking Janet like I don't
know if I like disagree that much
because when I think about like who
shows up to those parades it's like a
lot of kids
um this is what I feel like it's like a
family-friendly Affair so Janet did say
that uh she the stated that during
drinking during the parade doesn't set a
good model for younger fans and children
to follow but also that tragedy things
happen when alcohol is involved and it's
something that even the older fans don't
want to witness at a city-wide
celebration okay that is uh she's she
has like decent points but she's hella
dramatic this [__] yeah in the second
letter
um skip from Overland Park called out
specifically Patrick Mahomes and the
other players for drinking videos were
recorded throughout the parade that
featured Travis Kelsey of course
chugging a fireball shot thrown at him
and Holmes quickly consumed Coors Light
beer after Coors Light beer so I just
want to say like the concept of drinking
at the parade like isn't terrible to me
I think a lot of football culture is
centered around drinking and I think if
they're all on the thing like drinking
you know out of red cups or Bud Lights
and I don't think that's a big deal at
all
um but I do think like you know for the
parade it's in the middle of the day a
lot of kids come I don't know if you
need to be like black out on the float
like okay after for sure like you could
drink on the float like in a subtle way
I feel like people are always drinking
on floats but you never know you know
what I mean yeah yeah no I know but I
feel like so so often like someone from
the Sands throws a beer and the person
shotguns it that's it and it's cute and
funny parade things I'd have to look at
this parade versus parades prior what I
will like my first inclination was like
these guys you know they give their
whole half the year however many months
the season is they don't drink they
don't socialize they don't go out
they're very straight and narrow to
bring Pride to their city and they won
the [__] Super Bowl for you guys like
if they want to party on the bus like
true and
they're entitled to do that but then so
true the other part of me is like you
know there are young fans it's not a
good example alcohol is very dangerous
and over consumption of alcohol is can
lead to tragic results as Janet said
um
I just feel like there has to be a
middle ground yeah I think so too I
don't want to see like rules in place
you know no it doesn't need to be a dry
Affair but like the Andy Reid you know
could be like to his guys like you
represent your city
enjoy yourself
act with respect just keep in mind you
know who's watching kids who would dream
to be Travis Kelsey and Patrick Mahomes
like so just keep in mind you're of your
influence that's it yeah
I think that could be said I think like
a published published letters is like a
little dramatic conversation worth
having but I also think that the Chiefs
are just reflective of the larger
culture and drinking culture in general
they didn't invent this they didn't
invent chugging a beer especially in a
shot I mean football and beer go hand in
hand but like all around like this is
what our culture is now it's about binge
drinking it just is like that's just
think about literally every commercial
during the Super Bowl was different beer
companies and alcohol companies yeah but
they can't actually show them drinking
stuff but think about that's true what
what goes on like every single day no
you're right you're right everything is
about getting lit no I agree with with
your takes four and your takes four
against I'm standing firmly in the
middle I think it's an interesting
conversation I'd love to hear you know
more people's thoughts like what do
people think about this I think that
yeah they they could have uh I didn't
see the like all the footage so I think
in general they should act with respect
I also think it's okay to have like one
clown on the team
who's like being the crazy one but I
don't think the whole team should act
away I think there should be better role
models yeah I just also feel like this
is like an official
um like NFL event like you know after
the Super Bowl they had that
Chainsmokers after party Travis Kelsey
took her shirt off like that's at a club
like go wild and footage from that is
funny and whatever but the parade I
don't know why parades just in general
seem to me like things for kids honestly
it's like daylight out right yeah
it's an interesting conversation one
worth having it I think and I think
that's what the Kansas City Star
was getting at was getting at and
obviously Janet is going to take the
brunt you know everybody's understanding
she's being a little I hope she used an
alias she's no her whole middle last
name is in there and her hometown and
her address and phone number but I think
that if you're gonna write a letter to
the editor like
it's not Reddit you have to stand by
it's not rather
you have to stand by your letter
stand by your letter I you don't stand
by the letters
um I think it's an interesting combo one
in which I have no horse in yeah same
though I am always promoting safe
drinking so that's where I shall stand
well that is our show you guys thank you
so much for listening for being here
hope you enjoyed we'll see you tomorrow
for dear toasters if you tuned in today
for deer toasters you know we just did
so much on our plate and the words of
Shannon bedor this isn't my plate
tomorrow it will be my plate
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so at
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio I
heard of castbox all the places wherever
you listen to podcast find us the toast
leave a five star review about how
beautiful
stunning and smart we are oh and
wickedly talented hope you guys have an
increase don't forget to help someone
you love and we'll see you tomorrow love
you bye